and welcome back i have actually stepped
outside of our tv station literally into
our parking lot into what we call the
hughes house the howard hughes house
affectionately we have a special coming
up this weekend and i kind of want to
give you a preview of what you're going
to see in that special howard hughes
lived in this house for about a year
back in the 1950s we still have a lot of
the memorabilia from his time here in
fact this incredible this is when he
actually set the world aviation record
when he went around the world in like
three days and 19 hours and then over
here just above that is the ticker tape
parade when he arrived in new york city
after successfully traveling around the
world and setting that record so we're
going to dig into a lot of the secrets
and mysteries in this house because
howard hughes not only lived here for a
short time but he also owned channel
eight but this is actually one of the
kind of the cool little secrets and
mysteries here this is actually a memo
from howard hughes requesting photos of
women that he'd seen in a magazine
reportedly he would use them as like
maybe starlets or women he might date
but if you see at the very bottom there
there's actually a handwritten message
where he says no further pursuit
necessary howard hughes so in our
special we're going to dig into all
these little secrets and nooks and
crannies in our this house in our
backyard it's coming up sunday at 6 30
we hope that you will join us christian
back to you